はい初めまして株式会社アベ者の岡田洋介と申します
本当に今日はの運営犬見なすのがすごい頑張っていらっしゃってですねここであのお話
をさせていただくというのを大変光栄に思っております
それでですねまず一番最初にですね今回私が一番お伝えしたい言葉を一つ皆様にお見せ
したいと思っております
the best at プロジェクター future is ツイン便と言って
これは
安蘭けいと呼ばれるコンピューター研究者が回る経営者に言った言葉なんですけれども
これを日本語に訳しますと未来を予測する最善の方法はそれを発明することだという
ことなんですねまぁそれでこのアンケート人がいうものという方が発明したものは何か
と申しますと
パーソナルコンピューター今皆さんこっち
欄にいる方はほぼ全員が使われていると思います私はこのパーソナルコンピューターと
いうものですね
小学校5年生のという時にあってこれは絶対に世界を変えるものだというふうに確信を
してこのコンピュータサイエンスという分野を
研究そしてこの分野を使って起業しました
そして小学校二年生の時からインターネットと呼ばれるものがもうこの世界にありめぐ
されます張り巡らされました
これでこのインターネットを使ってどんなことができるんだろうということをずっと
考えてきましたその中で私が2つ勉強をずっとしてきたものがありますひとつは
プログラミングです
コンピューター動かす基礎的な言語になるものですね
それをずっと私は小学校5年生から勉強をしてきました
そしてそのプログラムの上で動くものそれを上でデザインをする
そういうものを私はずっと勉強の方をしてきました
そしてこの勉強してきたものを使っていかに社会が変わるかそういうところに私は
フォーカスおっしゃいました
そして大学生の頃一つあるものを売り上げました
それが研究ですコンピューター3 s という研究ヒーローに対して色んな国際学会
などに参加させていただき
この分野のいろんな事件を貯める
ことができましたそしてその分野をもっと社会に還元していきたいということである
商店街の活性化プロジェクトをウェブサイトを通じて行なってきました
そして
そんな中でもっともっとこのコンピューター3 s という分野を使って社会に価値を
貢献していきたいとおもい
私は大学3年生の時に友人たちと会社を立ち上げましたこの時私がすごい考えていたの
はどの道が正しいかということです
このまま大学を卒業して普通の企業に就職をする
それも一つ正しい道だと思っていますただし私は自分が選択した道
全部正しいものだと思いたいと思っていますですので私が選択した道は後からやはり
この位置はただし官だったんだと思えるぐらいに全力で武力を
して行きたいと思いました
そんなこともあって私は大学時代にソーシャルメディア系の会社を立ち上げました
仲間たちと24時間に近いぐらい勉強をして回発動して気ィどんな企業の子的かという
ことを話しました
そして実際ここ名古屋で会社を登記して会社を始めることもいたしました
しかしこの結果は見事に失敗をしました
なぜか
一番の原因はですね
まず開発コンピューターをずっと触っていましたので開発は全然可能でした
ただそれがいかにビジネスにつながるかというところ
大学生の当時の私は全く勉強することができなかった
だから私は改めて失敗をしたらというふうに思いましたその時
ある経営者の方に非常にかけていただきます
たそれが私が最初に就職をした会社である株式会社日未明の坂本幸蔵社長です
この時私はビジネスのことを全く知りませんでした
しかし坂本社長の方から1回家で使用していかないかという形で誘っていただき
そこで開発からスタートしデザインそして影響
をマーケティングそして最後は経営と呼ばれるようなマネジメントも勉強させて
いただきました
実際に
入社6ヶ月を絶った時にマネージャーをさせて頂き
ある事業部で四半期3カ月で数億円の
損益計算哨戒機それを実際にまわしてみるというところも経験させていただきました
そんな中でいろんなことを経験させていただきた中で
私はある日シリコンバレーに訪れることにしました
これは完全に墓も社長のご厚意で一度州シリコンバレーで一回見て後修行をしてこいと
いう形で行かせていただきましたその時に私は
apple
google
facebook
スタンフォードユニバースティと呼ばれる世界の中心
このコンピューター3 s と分野のいう分野の中心で仕事をされてる方勉強されて
いる方と直接お会いして話をする機会をいただきましたその時に彼ら
そして私
どこが一体違うんだろうという事を真剣がやりました
しかしこの答えはある意味で単純に頭がいいであったり
単純に
そもそもの育ちが違うというところではないというところに気がつきました
一番違ったところそれは何かというと本気度というところです
それは何か
彼らはずっとこのようなサイクルの中で動いてます
あるコンピューター3 s の分野で研究をする
そしてその研究成果を開発
実際に作っていくそしてそれをビジネスにつなげていく
それでビジネス練られたものをまた研究に再投資していく
この大学
起業非常に連携のとれた形で進んでいる
このようなフィールドずっと活躍をしましていました
その中で彼らがずっと言っている言葉が change the world でした
俺らは世界を変えるんだ絶対に自分たちは世界を変えてやるんだ
そういうことをずっと言ってましたこれはほかならね私は本気度だという風に考えまし
た
俺らは本当に世界を変えてやる自分はずっと世界を変えたいと思っていました
しかしそれが実際に行動できていなかった
私はすごい凹みました
なので私は自分が世界を変えたいと思って
新しく会社を立ち上げることにしました
この会社は本当に世界を見せていきたいとおもいます
日本だけではなくて世界に出ていける会社
日本から世界を変えるようなイノベーションをで作る会社
そこを私は日本で作りたいと考えましたではなぜ日本か
シリコンバレーでやればいいじゃないかと思うかもしれません
しかし日本には独特な風土や情緒と呼ばれるような特殊なものがあると感じた
います
これを見て美しいと思われると思いますこれは本当に日本独特の文化館であったりそう
いうものからこれは美しいというふうに重く思われています
実際にこのようなモミジを見てこれは本当にきれいだなと思った
それが
いろんなビジネスにつながるということは日本人しかできないビジネス
日本人しか作れないテクノロジーというのが存在しているのじゃないか
逆に日本人だけじゃないもっともっといろんな人が集まることによってできるビジネス
やテクノロジーが絶対あるんじゃないかと思って私は株式会社ビザという会社を創業し
ました
この会社
私はすごいを持っているのは会社というものは企業理念というものが存在しなければ
全く意味がないと思っています
ですので私はこの会社を立ち上げるときに企業理念というものを一番最初に定めました
この企業理念は何か
イノベーションで世界を変える私は絶対にこれをこの会社で成し遂げようと思ってい
ます
はっきりと申しまして
世界を変えられないようなビジネスを我々の会社は絶対しない
すごい利益が上がるけれどもこのビジネスをしていては一向に世界は変わらないそう
いうものは絶対にやらないんだという意思決定をする
そういった明確な維持決定基準をこの企業理念に設けています
それでこの良い日年から派生するものとして二つのビジョンを定めていますひとつは
すべての人に情報革命の恩恵を与える
う今皆さんは普通にコンピューターというものを触っていると思います
しかし本当に80歳90歳のおじいちゃんおばあちゃん
もしくは0歳の赤ちゃんまでがコンピューター
というものを使えているかと申しますそれは絶対ノーだと思います
しかし我々のテクノロジーを使うことによってそういう方たちにも情報革命の恩恵を
与えていきたい
そういうふうに思っておりますそしてもう一つ100年後の当たり前を創造するこれは
何かと申しますとはっきり言って今最先端のものを選んだはたくさんあると
持っていますしかし私たちは100年後
これは当たり前だこの生活になくてはならない
と呼ばれるものを当たり前を創造したいという風に考えています
そして今メンバーも約最初私がやっていた頃一人から始めたペンバーは約10%にまで
成長しライブの協力者も含めると30人ほどの組織今なろうとしています
そして今も
このような形でメンバーが楽しくお仕事をしている私はこういうものを見るとすごい
幸せな気持ちになっています
そして今我々がやっているテクノロジーが computer vision と呼ば
れるものです
これは何かというと人の目であったり
の作るような研究の方をさせていただいております最近機械学習コンピュータビジョン
というものが非常にこの分野では流行っています
この分野はなぜ流行るかと申しますと今まで今
牛太で無理とされていた両駅をこのテクノロジーを応用することによって解決できるか
もしれないということは我々としてはそれはこれクノロジーで解決するとかではなく
これでビジネスで解決していこうと思っています
それで実際に今われわれの会社はヨーロッパフランスて裁断2新規事業者である
オレンジをやっているインキュベーションプログラムにも採択いただいていたり
世界で5本の指に入るようなソフトウェア企業である
sa キー呼ばれる会社とも実際にコラボレーションの方をさせていただき
世界に向けて打って出ようとしています
そして今我々はシリコンバレーで行われたようなリサーチ
デベロップメントビジネスこの3つのサイクルを使った形でビジネスの方回させて
いただきます
実際に国内外の大学の先生方には非常に多く協力していただき多くの研究成果をを使っ
て事業化
そしてアドバイスの方をいただいておりますそれで実際には彼の方でそれを一般的に
ビジネスにできる形まで開発をさせていただきそれを多くの企業様
多くのユーザー様のところに届けるそれがわれわれの
一番の責任だという風に考えております
そうこの日本から我々はそれをやろうとしています
そしてこの日本という小さな国から世界に
打って出るそのテクノロジーベンチャーの初めての日辞令に我々なりたいと思ってい
ます
はいまたこの図なんですけれどもはっきり言ってこのたび道が正しい
もしくは間違っているそれは誰にもわかりません神様にもわからないかも知れませんん
しかし私は自分が選択した道
自分が正しいと思えた道をあとから振り返ったときにこれはやはり正しかったんだ
んと思えるように
今全力で努力をしていきたいというふうに思っています
最初にご紹介して言って聞かせていただいたことはざーベストへ行ってプレイディクツ
パフュ中
伊豆というインベントいっ
未来を予測する方法は自分たちでそれをつくっていくことなんです
ですので皆さん何か自分がこうしたいああしたい
いろんな思いがあると思いますその想いを実際に自分たちで作っていくそうすることに
よって自分たちが考える
明るい未来世界を変えるような未来が私は開けるようになると思っています
ああああああ
最後にもう一度この言葉です change the world
我々は絶対に世界を変えてみますします
ですので皆さんも何かぜひ世界を変えるアイデアを実践してください
そして実際にここにいる全員でよろしくは ustream をご覧になっている
には方全員で世界中の方々で世界をより一歩でも良いものにしか使えていく世界
を変えて生きていればいいと思っておりますはい
ありがとうございました